[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
je suis pour lui
ici je ne mens pas fodé bien occupé
maintenant j'attends le thème du grand
prix je le crois la chaîne qui monte à
la boulaye à fix me willy près ce que tu
veux je le paye parce qu'on a rien sans
rien voir venir la crise et par écrit
ces projets là je plaque sur scène
rappelle moi mais pourquoi tu sur coup
j'ai besoin de sous la halle aux
mecquois s'armeront pour lui
je suis ici
oui
je sois une charge montrez-moi allô allô
[Musique]
ces histoires diplôme janvier inquiète
ma mère elle n'est pas comme moi je te
laisserai jamais fumé jeunesse jamais
temps mais jamais jamais être moi quest
ix propos ça fait qu'on rattrape pas le
temps j'ai raté de grands moments
quand je suis là j'en fais trop j'ai
peur de me dire ah vous dirais pourquoi
tu saoules mais où j'ai besoin de sous
la vie à l'eau les gros ça me rend fou
je m'ennuie
je sais richard chico crise
coûte clause ici soit une star mon père
mois à l'eau
il
bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça
alonso l'album 100% il est déjà disque
d'or noir merci d'hérault qu'est-ce que
je te qui a tant fait de table je t'aime
un micro non mais quoi on va leur dire
bonsoir tu vois la donne et je suis fier
de toi merci vous comme un gros bisou
c'est très gentil en tout cas merci de
me recevoir
super mais là non mais je mangeais qui
fait alors si le public terrible
aventure alors que tu partes parce que
je vois que tu as une belle barbichette
ouais elle est bien fourni elle est bien
garni on va être sur scène c'est ce
qu'on dit de moi quand je suis tout nu
également frérot est ce que tu veux bien
qu'on se fasse tous les deux ici là sur
cette caméra on sera un jeu te tiens tu
me tiens par la barbichette à vue pour
calmy rey c'est parti c'était pas du
tout prévu cette séquence peut durer
deux heures je te dirais bien la chance
alors les paroles c'est je te tiens tu
me tiens par la barbichette le premier
de nous deux qui rira aura une [ __ ] à
mouches qui s'écrivent au prompteur
oasis alors il va alors c'est inquiète
pas tu me suivront je te tiens tu me
tiens par la barbichette le premier de
nous
qu'il ira aura une [ __ ] ça va durer
mille ans quoi qu'il advienne à la fin
sa série pigalle
c'est de la triche
[Applaudissements]
la phrase la plus drôle de l'histoire de
thé pmp ya quand même une meuf d'un
public qui était premier degré à mort
premier dogues à mort sur le dakar
michel mais c'est de la triche c'est
agathe ou prou agathe ont croqué preuves
mais c'est de la triche
vous allez voir qu'à gâteau proulx n'est
pas dans son état normal aujourd'hui
gelée suite c'est pourquoi dans un
instant
[Applaudissements]